attorney michael avenatti who represents
stormy Daniels joins us at the table
good to see you again good morning
so already Michael Cohen's attorney is
saying listen then you all are accusing
him of false things they said that he
did not have anything to do with this
incident about stormy Daniels being
threatened if she was in fact threatened
or if even such a person exists and
you've been hit with a cease and desist
order and they're asking for an apology
and retraction what are you saying about
that this morning Gail we're only
getting started
Michael Cohen has zero credibility we're
gonna prove it his statements thus far
in connection with this matter are
laughable this is a man who has a
history of thuggish behavior using
intimidation tactics and trying to step
on little people and as it relates to my
client it's gonna come to an end and
we're going to show the American people
exactly who Michael Cohen is and exactly
what happened in connection with this
incident including what happened with
the agreement and this $130,000 payment
and you're insisting that you have
evidence that proves this we are going
to establish evidence and we already
have some evidence that certainly
establishes and why haven't you done
that yet you were teased as on Twitter
with the CD a picture's worth a thousand
words that seems like a big tease why
are you teasing us well have it why not
why not produce it no it's not a big
tease we're in the process of a legal
case we're going to be methodical
surgical and smart in the way that we go
about doing this the CD the tweet of the
CD or the DVD yeah was meant to send a
warning shot that mr. Cohen and the
president better be very careful what
they come out and state regarding my
client isn't it interesting Gail that we
have a president that will tweet about
the most mundane matters but he won't
tweet about my client the affair the
agreement or the $130,000 payment you
know why he won't treat about it because
it's true it's a hundred percent true
and what's on the trucks on that CD
what's on that I'm not going to disclose
what's on the CD right now at IDEO
images I'm not going to disclose you can
ask me ten different times
I'm not going to disclose what's on it
right now disclose it will disclose it
at the appropriate time but where where
where is nothing where is well if you
think I'm bluffing
you should ask a lot of the people that
I've litigated against successfully over
the last 15 years you ask them about if
I'm the kind of guy that Bluffs so what
are you holding out for more money what
is it that you want no we're not holding
out for more money we're gonna be
methodical we're gonna treat this like
any other case although it's a very
high-profile case we're gonna be smart
about it we're gonna be strategic about
it well you know last night we learned
some very salacious salacious things
okay so the President of the United
States they had a one-night stand number
one he allegedly likes to be spanked
with a magazine with his picture on the
cover with his underwear he allegedly
sits on a bed perch all that's very
salacious very juicy and very tawdry I
think when you think president just
president porn star in one sentence is a
lot of jarring for a lot of people what
exactly why does this matter to the
American people I really want you to lay
this out why cuz I think a lot of people
watch that interview last time they went
below okay they had an affair years ago
a one-night stand years ago she was paid
how was she paid tell us why this
matters to us Gail it should matter to
every American because it's all about
the cover up it's about the lies and
deceit that have been laid out to the
American people by mr. Cohen and mr.
Trump by his surrogates it is about the
hiding of the knowledge of the president
relating to the agreement and the
negotiation of the agreement as well as
this $130,000 payment mr. Cohen wants
the American people to believe that this
is all false and he just paid the
hundred and thirty thousand dollars even
though there was no basis to the
allegation well if that's true Gail
every viewer right now should call
Michael Cohen's office here in New York
City claim they had an affair with the
president and according to mr. Cohen
he's gonna send you one hundred and
thirty thousand dollars immediately so I
would urge every viewer to do that it's
laughable it's a joke I asked you last
time you were here I asked you
specifically if you had evidence that
the hundred and thirty thousand dollars
that Michael Cohen that it came from
somewhere other than his own pocket and
you said you might are you going to
disclose that anytime soon that's the
appropriate time yes okay also the
person who threatened your clients
stormy Daniels in 2011 do you have any
indication of who that might be
we're in the process of trying to
discover exactly who that might be but
you can imagine how terrifying
that was for my client she's still being
contacted have you been contacted by
federal investigators for the special
counsel I'm not gonna answer that
question
is she still being threatened are you
worried about her life is she worried
about the safety
well absolutely today absolutely I mean
she receives threats on a near hourly
basis now we don't have anything tying
those to mr. cohen or mr. trump to be
clear but she's certainly scared for her
safety and the safety of her family in
light of this so she's admitted Michael
that she's lied before where she said
listen nothing happened between her and
the president why should the American
people believe that she's now telling
the truth I think the American people
were able to observe her under some
pretty tough questions by Anderson
Cooper they were able to observe what
she said her demeanor etc and I think
that eighty to ninety percent of the
American people found her to be credible
and believable all right the story to be
continued right thank you to be
contended morning absolutely to be
continued we're just getting started all
right thank you very much for joining us
at the table we should note that we did
invite the president's lawyer that's
Michael Cohen who we've been talking
about to give his reaction on CBS this
morning he has not yet responded to our
invitation